Speaker 1: . Let's hear from some
people in the audience. We take calls
on the Friday show via discord at David Pakman
dot com slash Discord. Let's start today with
Nevin from Tennessee. Nevin, welcome
to the show. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, David, I had to question
first of all.
Speaker 1: There's
something there's something that just banged in
the background. You said you have to question.
Speaker 2: Yes. Yes. Okay. Okay. So firstly, do
you think that progressive economic reforms such
as universal healthcare, tuition forgiveness,
etc. can be accomplished without a big economic
depression, such as for the New Deal during FDR.
Speaker 1: You said, can can we avoid an economic
depression through programs like the New Deal?
Speaker 2: Yes. Like universal health care
or news programs? Like stuff like that.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, generally speaking,
government spending that is carefully thought,
carefully conceived to be economically stimulative
through what we call demand side stimulus is a
good way to both do good things for the people
and also to help the economy. The devil is in
the details of the programs and the spending.
Speaker 2: Well, okay. And I'd also like
to ask you, what can liberals like myself
do in our house?
Speaker 1:
Did you say for the progressive cause?
Speaker 2: Yes.
Speaker 1: Well, get involved in local races at
some level, even in southern red states. Is there
an opportunity to replace a right wing state rep
or state senator with someone more progressive? Is
there an opportunity to get involved in a school
board? There's lots of local opportunities and
also you can still phone bank for any race
across the country that you want. So like,
imagine that you're in Alabama and there's no
likely Democratic Senate challenger in Alabama.
You can phone bank for Fetterman in Pennsylvania.
Right, or you can whatever. So there's there's no
shortage of ways to get involved.
Speaker 2:
Yeah. That's all. Thanks for taking my call.
Speaker 1: Nevin, I have to ask, where are you
calling from? The noise in the background is wild.
Speaker 2: I'm on a bus ride.
Speaker 1: Oh, you're on a bus right now?
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: Do people around, you
know you're on The David Pakman Show.
Speaker 2: They probably don't know what it is.
Speaker 1: They don't know. All right,
Evan, thank you for the call.
Speaker 2: You're welcome. All right.
Speaker 1: Nevin Nevin from
thank you, Nevin from a bus
in Tennessee. That is something else. I don't know
that we've ever had a call from a bus necessarily.